[Music]
[Music]
I'm aware of how the protesters are
about a hundred meters away last
again the take outside has gone out
[Applause]
we're gonna keep anything
so this is the new front lines that
they've established hand the way they
try to get them out the good
it doesn't like again they're going to
try and fire some tear gas to disperse
these protesters you see there's a lot
of noise that they're not a great
that's for trying intimidate people you
get them to keep moving but even these
protesters down I think the main
difference with yesterday is yesterday
there was a very prescribed exit route
for protesters negotiated by protesters
companies talked to the train station
here we go let's take out five
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the keeping guy forward fold it forward
the protesters bill that faraway down
without thinking right here they're
really moving apart a lot of speed and
they just keep retreat to keep retreat
together there's no real resistance from
the protesters they don't have their
barricades so this will just keep
happening I imagine okay break your line
we can fade recuperated getting back
together regrouping either time take the
forwards see where the protesters going
and they get ready for the next phase of
action
[Applause]
this isn't where we were yesterday which
is not the outskirts this is a dissenter
bullfrog code these are shops he's
estranged people here on a Sunday
afternoon these sorts of seeds
incredible is again the spiral it's
violent to chaos that we're saving the
city is absolutely remarkable
again another pause it's worth betting
as well that we're expecting the press
conference tomorrow from the state
capital the Chinese takeout some people
at Republic of China they're going to
talk about their plans for dealing with
the unrest I don't know how much this
will factor into that press conference
where the decision has been made where
the Chinese leadership now has a
strategy for how to deal with our code
because this isn't a strategy so far
this is that whole protest big paired
against let's be a bit careful here
because it looks like is about
[Music]
so it's going to be fast we're not sure
exactly what's happening
these are exciting right when I camera
trying to get us to go away you know
until you got food pod
[Applause]
so we just hear the protesters that's
nothing it can happen
let's go beating anything whatever their
camera and how sharing that defies check
that determination
you can see they're pitching out a
little bit aware hold it they get the
counts both so they know what to expect
they came here ready to expect this they
might you think driven back further than
they would say I'm telling you to get a
key to everything
but they just have a goat for me to
treat there we go pull the protesters up
again no open it or not hey guys
yesterday rubber bullets were fired as
well
[Music]
this is a very small area for four
people gathering what's going on what
lady do I have hook code the seats of
central hub phones
there's a bit of a static I mean you can
look at some of these cookies don't my
god I think it's not the child a slim
adjoint of the piece this is night of
sight the flagstones the police seem to
be missing if you're ordering it other
streets they said phonetic the people
here come for that seat when there's
another barricade down there so move
everyone fat with another fire cave the
police reports are given out so that
everyone just that main thing the
protesters here urging everyone to get
back behind them that side is kind of
guard as they wait for the next loose
action a lot of people still really
around this very fluid situation if you
look at over their heart you can see the
police have barricaded that Street now
there's a next set of facts and I
imagine they want for you to say before
the other side
and there's one signal that's it and
that's gonna stay here so they're coming
down this side they really try to force
everyone into this main shadow I think
we can expect a similar thing on the
other side now the protesters were
chasing ham the police in front of them
liaison office that's a good two seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
the protesters like a bit cookies
keeping their eyes prod even as the
cookies make their way down here
protesters have been forced back as well
they seem to be giving people enough
time to try make it out these streets
before they do the final care it's
really very hard to gauge how many
protesters here we know thousands
earlier at the city they went their
different ways sorry three different
axes somewhere north of itself and
they've ended up different things so
different barricades around the city
this feels like a quiet survivor is it
everyone's regrouping button please
there come a lot closer to they've got
their gas masks as well the protesters
has tagged people in the crowd
what the what if I stayed there wasn't
what I Nev need that sort of fits the
pattern of what we've been seeing here
so far peaceful protest fine large we've
got a local element who are up for that
fight with the police even though the
vast nail guns I've been taking homemade
weapons there's so much fury had so much
idea I think that's what's changed about
the quad core over the last just the
last few days really off the seven weeks
of protests mass protests over what
started with the extradition bill figure
over the extradition bill that was a
bill that was put before dark road code
register so saying that since this could
be active I super bug code to be lab
China critics said well you can't get a
fair trial and they're not tryna because
it's under the control of the Chinese
Communist Party big protests over that
but since then there's more absolute
fury and anger over what protesters see
as police violence they say a couple of
things possible that he's been
heavy-handed how they deal with
protesters but also last weekend there
was an attack on some protesters weren't
returning home at U n log so they had
been protesting they came home to a
suburb of code and it was set apart by a
gag of men in white shirts both five
people were sent to hospital as a result
of that attack and a lot of people have
been asking where where the police when
that happened you can see the police out
in for tonight but they weren't there
from outside
so the crazy hair in these protests are
laughs I would say about police
complaining about what they said police
brutality so corrupt police the peace
know the law but they break the know the
other half is about you know for
democracy for God a general cry for
freedom and in all of this you have
toured debated two-faced people have a
tow hook on right now with the
government is not would govern officials
there's no spokespeople really going out
tried to stab protesters trying to even
condemn they would say this is not the
way to do things it is the people versus
the police there's no other government
representation I think that's why you're
having these very snappy big standoff
these clashes because that's the only
Avenue for a resolution at the moment
and what happens is they're allowed to
protest for a while then the police move
about you can see the bang you can see
that they're they're getting ready for a
last big person that period I think as I
say they're giving those protesters who
do want to leave the trots to leave well
as you want to stay and that's what
these guys over there they're not going
anywhere they could stay and be the last
of this resistance but this is clearly
you know is it operation to clear these
streets to remove these protesters
profit
we're gonna keep see how it goes but
again this is the pattern they've been
some corralling people there but that
Street looks almost cleared out that
stays Park that's where the police are
gonna be going you can see all those are
brothers up turn against the incoming
against the incoming grenades and then
let's take another look at the police
over here
if you see that got there ready to go
just adding off lots of lights in the
background what we've seen all day is
the police have been recycling squads
[Applause]
okay recycle Eastmont so this is a
moment of calm it has it become we're
going to stay here we'll bring you the
latest as it happens in what is clearly
a developing situation